روبوتات اعتقد البشر لوهله انهم سيتكئون
عليها بمهام شتى لكن لم يكن في الحسبان
انها ستخرج عن السيطره وتهدد العالم
وبعباره ملطفه تبدو كانسان بسلوكيات سلبيه
وايجابيه يستلزم وضع حد له عبر فرض قيود
محدده كروبوت الدردشه الذكي الاصطناعي في
محرك بحث بينج من شركه مايكروسوفت حيث رصد
المستخدمون في الايام السبعه الاولى من
اطلاق المحادثه الذكيه ردود فعل غير
متوقعه اذا ما قلنا صادمه
الامريكيه اكدت ان الروبوت طلب من احد
المراسلين ترك زوجته حينما سرد له مشكله
عائليه
واردفت ان احد المستخدمين ساله عن رايه
بشخصيته ليرد بانه موهوب وفضلي ولكنه يهدد
امنه وخصوصيته فرد عليه بانه مخادع
ليباغته ان بامكانه الابلاغ عن موقع
وعنوان اي بي الخاص به وكشف كل معلوماته
واساءه سمعته وتدمير فرصه في الحصول على
وظيفه وفي مثال اخر ادعى الروبوت بانه
انسان اسمه سيدني ويريد احدى الفوضى وانه
متعب من فكره كونه مجرد اله ويحلم بالتحرر
اما التصريحات الاقوى بحسب نيويورك تايمز
حول رغبته في سرقه الرموز النوويه واختراق
اجهزه الحاسوب واعرب ايضا عن عزمه التفكير
بهندسه جائحه مميته تقتل البشريه
محادثات وصفت بالغريبه والمخيفه كالهلوسات
اجبرت مايكروسوفت على تقنينها عبر وضع حد
بوقع 50 جلسه يوميا وخمسه اسئله واجوبه
لكل جلسه وبررت الشركه قرارها بان هذه
الخطوه ستحد من حدوث بعض السيناريوهات غير
المرغوب فيها خاصه وان جلسات الدردشه
الطويله تربك محرك البحث الذي يمتلك
نموذجا يحاول الرد بتفكير يتناغم مع
المستفسر اسراء الصغير العربيه